This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. It can feel like everywhere you look, someone's accusing someone else of peddling fake news. Why did you see an N-reportor between that false son, fake tweet about the migrant children being in cages? A recurring internet story says Pope Francis endorsed Hillary Clinton. Post-Abounded have circulated Twitter and Facebook, but it's bogus. How the fake news is saying we're fake news. But the story is false.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。你可能会觉得，无论你看向哪里，总有人在指责别人兜售假新闻。为什么你会在那个虚假的儿子、关于移民儿童被关在笼子里的假推特之间看到N-reportor？一则反复出现的网络传闻称，教皇方济各支持了希拉里·克林顿。关于堕胎的文章在推特和脸书上广为流传，但它们都是假的。假新闻怎么能说我们是假新闻呢？但这个故事是假的。
Fake news is the enemy. It is fake news. These charges and countercharges about inaccuracy, bias, and fabrication can see modern. In fact, they're deeply rooted in the history of American journalism. There are patterns and resonances that recur and recur and recur. But if there are similarities between the present and the past, there are also areas of sharp divergence. There are things about our present moment that are unique
假新闻是敌人。这就是假新闻。这些关于不准确、偏见和捏造的指控和反指控看起来可能很现代。事实上，它们深深植根于美国新闻业的历史中。其中有不断重复、重复又重复的模式和共鸣。但是，如果现在和过去有相似之处，也存在尖锐的分歧领域。我们当下的某些方面是独一无二的
and uniquely dangerous. I think there are consequential differences in what's going on now in the Trump administration. Some very important and nerve-wracking differences. This week on Hidden Brain, what the history of fake news in the United States reveals about an important tension at the heart of journalism. Should reporters think about their readers and listeners as consumers or as citizens? Should the media give people what they want or what they need.
且具有独一无二的危险性。我认为，特朗普政府现在正在发生的事情有着重大的不同。一些非常重要且令人神经紧张的不同。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨美国假新闻的历史揭示了新闻业核心的一个重要张力。记者应该把读者和听众视为消费者还是公民？媒体应该给人们他们想要的还是他们需要的。
Andy Tucker is a professor at Columbia University and she studies the history of what we now call fake news. Andy, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. I want to start with a story from your book, Froth and Scum. You describe a crime that took place on Sunday morning in 1836. What was the crime and how did it first come to light?
安迪·塔克是哥伦比亚大学的教授，她研究我们现在所称的假新闻的历史。安迪，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。我想从你书中的一个故事开始，书名是《浮沫与渣滓》。你描述了1836年一个星期天早晨发生的一起谋杀案。这起案件是什么，它是如何最初曝光的？
Early that morning, a young woman who lived at a house of prostitution in New York City was found hacked to death in her bed and her body was set on fire. It was a sensational crime as it would be in any era, but it became particularly frenzied and important because there was a new kind of newspaper in the city. And suddenly there was competition to cover a sensational story, more sensational than the next guy. It became what I think is one of the first media circuses in US history to figure out who was the guilty party,
那天清晨，纽约市一家卖淫场所的一名年轻女工被发现在床上被乱刀砍死，尸体还被放火焚烧。这是一起轰动的犯罪，在任何时代都是如此，但它变得特别疯狂和重要，因为城里出现了一种新报纸。突然间，大家开始争相报道这个耸人听闻的故事，一个比一个更轰动。我认为它成为了美国历史上最早的媒体旋涡之一，人们急于弄清谁是罪魁祸首，
who killed her and why. So police arrest a guy, put him on trial, but very quickly this new kind of newspaper, which is the penny press, springs into action, editors serve up all the lurid details of the case, including several unverified claims, and insist that they are acting in the public good. The public good was a really important part of how the new newspapers were covering this.
是谁杀害了她以及为什么。于是警察逮捕了一个人，让他受审，但很快这种被称为“廉价报纸”的新型报纸就开始行动了，编辑们抛出该案的所有骇人听闻的细节，包括几个未经核实的说法，并坚称他们是在为公众利益行事。公众利益是这些新报纸报道方式中非常重要的一个部分。
They said we're doing something really different. Newspapers before that had been generally very partisan. They were funded by political parties. They were operated by political party functionaries. they were an accepted part of the political system. The new penny press did something different. They said, we're just giving information to people who want information. We are not connected anywhere, we're free, we're independent, we can tell you anything, we're not we're not bound by any political ties. So you have the right to know what's going on and where the ones
他们说我们在做一些非常不同的事情。在此之前的新闻报纸通常都非常有党派色彩。它们由政党资助。它们由政党官员运营。它们是政治体制中被接受的一部分。新型廉价报纸做了一些不同的事情。他们说，我们只是在向想要信息的人提供信息。我们在任何地方都没有联系，我们是自由的，我们是独立的，我们可以告诉你任何事，我们不受任何政治纽带的束缚。所以你有权知道发生了什么，而我们就是那个
who are going to tell you. We're doing it for the public good. How do they go about covering the story? Oh, it was quite a circus. There was no such thing as a reporter at that time. The political newspapers had an editor who kind of thought and wrote. Then the Penny Press had to invent the idea of the reporter, the person who went around doing shoe leather observation
要告诉你的人。我们这样做是为了公众利益。他们是如何着手报道这个故事的？哦，这简直是一场马戏团般的闹剧。那时候根本没有什么记者的概念。政治报纸只有一个负责思考和写作的编辑。然后廉价报纸不得不发明记者的概念，即那个四处奔波、进行实地观察
and investigation, poking around, asking questions, trying to get into the crime scene. All of this was brand new. Some people were horrified that these nosy little people were buzzing around, being, you know, asking embarrassing questions and talking to people who were much higher than them in station.
和调查、四处打听、提出问题、试图进入犯罪现场的人。所有这一切都是全新的。有些人对这些到处窥探、嗡嗡乱叫、问一些令人尴尬的问题、并与社会地位远高于他们的人交谈的小人物感到震惊。
But a lot of readers thought this was just great. This was news that finally was catering to them. This was ordinary middle class, working class people who were not terribly interested in all of the Washington scandals and embryos. And this was what they wanted to know. Bringing people what they wanted. Newspapers began to treat their audiences like consumers.
但许多读者认为这太棒了。这终于迎来了迎合他们的全新闻。这是普通的、中产阶级和工人阶级的人，他们对华盛顿所有的丑闻和内幕并不十分感兴趣。而这正是他们想知道的。把人们想要的东西带给他们。报纸开始把他们的受众当作消费者来对待。
They began to ask what their audiences might want to read and to shape their stories to cater to those demands. This sometimes meant a blatant disregard for the truth. The Herald wanted a more respectable readership. The Herald wanted middle-class people. to those demands. This sometimes meant a blatant disregard for the truth. The Herald wanted a more respectable readership. The Herald wanted middle-class people. So the Herald decided that the nice middle-class young man who had been accused of the crime was actually innocent. He was a poor lamb who was being framed by evil and designing madams and police officers. The sun was a newspaper much more closely tied to the working class.
他们开始询问他们的受众可能想读什么，并调整他们的故事来迎合这些需求。这有时意味着对真相的公然漠视。《先驱报》想要更有声望的读者群。《先驱报》想要中产阶级的人。来迎合这些需求。这有时意味着对真相的公然漠视。《先驱报》想要更有声望的读者群。《先驱报》想要中产阶级的人。因此，《先驱报》断定，那个被指控犯罪的温文尔雅的中产阶级年轻人其实是无辜的。他是一个可怜的羔羊，正被邪恶、诡计多端的老鸨和警察陷害。《太阳报》则是一份与工人阶级联系更紧密的报纸。
They wanted to give a story that was more appealing to the working class, which was this poor woman on the fringe of society is being abused and exploited by rich and powerful people. So they both looked at the same crime and had entirely different interpretations based on what they thought their readers would prefer to hear. In some ways, it's a very democratic approach to news. It's telling these readers, you can make up your own minds. You can look at the case and you can figure out what you believe based on your own intuition and your own intelligence.
他们想讲述一个对工人阶级更有吸引力的故事，那就是这个处于社会边缘的可怜女人正受到富有和权势之人的虐待和剥削。因此，他们两人看着同一桩罪行，却根据他们认为读者更愿意听到的内容，得出了完全不同的解释。从某种程度上说，这是一种非常民主的新闻运作方式。它在告诉这些读者，你可以自己下定论。你可以查看这个案件，并根据你自己的直觉和智慧来弄清楚你相信什么。
You don't need smart elites to tell you this. So even though each newspaper kind of fudged and shaded the truth, they did it on the understanding that readers would choose one or the other. And that was that was part of their pitch. You can figure it out. You can decide. That was really exciting. And of course, as you're talking right now, I'm hearing echoes to the present day where, you know, if you're a Democrat, you have your preferred cable news channel. If you're a conservative, you have your preferred cable news channel. It really is not that different than it was, you know, 200 years ago.
你不需要聪明的精英来告诉你这些。因此，尽管每份报纸都在一定程度上篡改和掩盖了真相，但他们这样做是建立在读者会二选一的理解之上的。这就是他们宣传的一部分。你可以自己弄明白。你可以自己决定。这真的令人兴奋。当然，当你现在说话的时候，我听到了当今时代的共鸣，你知道的，如果你是民主党人，你有你偏爱的情绪新闻频道。如果你是保守派，你有你偏爱的情绪新闻频道。这与200年前相比真的没有太大区别。
Now, in some ways, it's very, very similar. There are patterns and resonances that recur and recur and recur. One of the things that your book and other essays and writing reveal is that at times of great conflict that allows people to sort of look at the same facts and reach very different conclusions about them. And of course, a civil war, you know, is sort of maybe exhibit A in this because you have the enormous conflict happening within the country and you have the press basically describing what happened in ways that are diametrically opposed to other publications. Do you have examples of fake news during the Civil War?
现在，在某些方面，它们非常、非常相似。其中有不断重复、重复又重复的模式和共鸣。你的书以及其他论文和文章揭示的一点是，在巨大冲突的时期，人们可以借此查看相同的事实，并对它们得出截然不同的结论。当然，内战可能是一个典型的例子，因为国家内部发生了巨大的冲突，而媒体基本上以与其它出版物截然相反的方式描述了所发生的事情。你在内战期间有假新闻的例子吗？
There's one strange one in which a battle of P. Ridge Arkansas, which is in the Wild Northwestern corner of the Ozarks, very far from everything. And a reporter for the New York Tribune writes a very long elaborate, really thorough, really good piece about the battle that later, two of his colleagues say he made up completely because he wasn't there. He hadn't made it to the battlefield in time. It was so hard to get to. He listened to other people. He read other reports. He used his own knowledge, he understood what might have happened.
有一个奇怪的例子，在阿肯色州皮里奇的一场战役中，该战役位于欧扎克斯山脉狂野的西北角，远离一切。一位《纽约论坛报》的记者写了一篇非常长、精心构思、非常透彻、非常好的关于这场战役的文章，后来他的两位同事说他是完全捏造的，因为他根本不在那里。他没有及时赶到战场。那个地方太难到达了。他听取了别人的意见。他阅读了其他报道。他运用了自己的知识，他理解了可能发生的事情。
It was common knowledge among many journalists, but they were very, they were very wary about revealing that. They would refer to it, but they didn't use the name of the reporter. They were trying to protect their own guy rather than worrying about whether this was truthful and whether audiences might be misled. By the end of the 19th century, journalism had become a sort of wild west. There were very few rules for how reporters should operate. This is the time of the Spanish-American war
这在许多记者中是公开的秘密，但他们对透露这一点非常警惕。他们会提及它，但他们没有使用该记者的名字。他们试图保护自己人，而不是担心这是否真实以及受众是否会被误导。到了19世纪末，新闻业已经变成了一种狂野的西部。关于记者应该如何运作的规则少之又少。这是美西战争的时期
and the yellow press, the very sensational press, spearheaded by William Randolph Hurst and Joseph Pulitzer in New York, and they're competing with each other. The fake news often gets worse and worse at times of intense competition. They are making up all sorts of stuff. It's a war with low stakes and low casualties relatively, so it seems open to all sorts of creativity and interpretation. It becomes so sensational that people begin to think of journalism as incapable of telling the truth.
和黄色新闻，即极具轰动效应的报纸，由纽约的威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特和约瑟夫·普利策带头，他们在相互竞争。在激烈竞争的时期，假新闻往往变得越来越糟糕。他们捏造各种各样的事情。这是一场风险较低、伤亡相对较小的战争，所以它似乎向各种创造力和解释敞开了大门。它变得如此耸人听闻，以至于人们开始认为新闻业没有能力说出真相。
There are new technologies too. There is the motion picture. Edison's film crews go down to Cuba in order to film, they say, to film what's going on. Turns out these new motion picture cameras are not very good. They're really clumsy. They don't take pictures well. So instead, what happens is Edison runs a lot of these little newsreels, actualities of what's going on in Cuba, but he actually stages them in the mountains of West Orange and New Jersey. So there's a lot going on that's really bad and an of growing understanding that journalism is at a crisis point that nobody believes it. So there are many forms of fake news that we can laugh about, but it's also clear that many journalism outlets have used fake
也有新技术。那就是电影。爱迪生的电影摄制组前往古巴进行拍摄，他们说，是为了拍摄正在发生的事情。结果发现这些新的电影摄像机并不是很好。它们真的很笨拙。它们拍出的照片并不好。所以相反，发生的事情是爱迪生播放了许多这些小新闻片，也就是古巴正在发生的事情的实况，但实际上他是在新泽西州西奥兰治的山里摆拍的。因此，有很多非常糟糕的事情正在发生，并且人们越来越认识到新闻业正处于危机点，没有人相信它。所以有许多形式的假新闻我们可以一笑置之，但也很明显，许多新闻机构利用假
news and accusations of fake news to push really disturbing agendas. You mentioned how the Atlanta Constitution had reported on lynchings, specifically the work of IDB Wells. Yes, in 1894, the Atlanta Constitution had a headline in which it dismissed as fake news reporting by IDB Wells on particularly gruesome lynching that involved African-American women and children. And Ida Wells was a crusading journalist who was exposing fearlessly the epidemic of lynching
新闻和对假新闻的指控来推动令人不安的议程。你提到《亚特兰大宪法报》是如何报道林奇事件的，特别是埃 Ida B·韦尔斯的著作。是的，在1894年，《亚特兰大宪法报》有一个标题，其中将伊达·B·韦尔斯关于特别可怕的、涉及非裔美国妇女和儿童的林奇事件的报道斥为假新闻。而伊达·韦尔斯是一位倡导改革的记者，她无所畏惧地揭露了林奇事件的流行病
in the South and the Atlantic Constitution, which was a very important influential paper for the White South, was refusing to acknowledge this and and by using the term fake dismissed her claims and made and made it very difficult to discuss the issue in public So at a certain point in American journalism, you know the virtues or the the ideals of objectivity and neutrality, accuracy these come to be seen as cardinal rules for the press. When did this happen and what prompted it? That began at the very end of the 19th century, the very beginning of the 20th century, when objectivity and impartiality started to become news values. One of the key players here is the New York Times, which has just been bought by Adolf Oaks in 1896. He decides he's going to make the New York Times, which has just been bought by Adolf Oaks in 1896. And he decides he's
在南方，《亚特兰大宪法报》是白人南方一份非常重要且具影响力的报纸，却拒绝承认这一点，并通过使用“假”一词驳回了她的说法，使得在公共场合讨论这个议题变得非常困难。因此，在美国新闻业的某个特定时刻，客观性、中立性和准确性的美德或理想被视为新闻界的核心规则。这是什么时候发生的，是什么促成了这一点？这始于19世纪末、20世纪初，当时客观性和公正性开始成为新闻价值观。其中的关键参与者之一是《纽约时报》，它刚于1896年被阿道夫·奥克斯收购。他决定让《纽约时报》刚于1896年被阿道夫·奥克斯收购。他决定让
going to make the New York Times a paper of record. He's going to make it the final arbiter and matters of fact. It's going to be trustworthy and it's going to be decent. One of its motto's, of course, all the news that's fit to print, but another of its motto was, it will not soil the breakfast cloth. So he was making a real point of being decent and honorable which went along with being more accurate. So all of these these different qualities are combining. So that by the early 20th century the idea of objectivity, neutrality, impartiality, those ideas are becoming more conventional in certain kinds of newspapers. The Yellow Press continues to be
《纽约时报》成为权威记录报纸。他要让它成为事实层面的最终仲裁者。它将是值得信赖的，它将是体面的。它的座右铭之一当然是“所有适于刊登的新闻”，但它的另一个座右铭是“它不会弄脏早餐布”。因此，他非常明确地要做到体面和光荣，这也伴随着更高的准确性。因此，所有这些不同的品质结合在了一起。所以在20世纪初，客观性、中立性、公正性的理念开始在某些类型的报纸中变得更加传统。黄色新闻继续保持
yellow and people love that too. But the interesting thing of course is that even as there are these new norms of fairness and objectivity, accuracy, the norm that basically publishing, fake or fabricated news is wrong, this does not do a way with the problem of fake news. In some ways you could argue maybe it even exacerbates the problem. When you think about in more recent times, the New York Times publishing reports citing on-name sources that Iraq had weapons of mass destruction. You can dismiss the New York Times as the penny press or the yellow press. This becomes part of the drumbeat that actually leads to war.
黄色，人们也喜欢这样。但有趣的是，当然，即使有了这些关于公平、客观和准确的新闻规范，即出版虚假或捏造新闻是错误的这一规范，这并没有消除假新闻的问题。从某种程度上你可以说，它甚至可能加剧了这个问题。当你想到近来《纽约时报》发表引用匿名消息来源称伊拉克拥有大规模杀伤性武器的报道时。你可以把《纽约时报》贬为廉价报纸或黄色新闻。这成为了最终导致战争的鼓点的一部分。
It's really complicated. once a newspaper announces that it is going to be truthful, neutral, objective. Once it announces it's going to be accountable, then it's faced with the real question, what happens if we get it wrong? How do you make up for that? Do you undermine your own credibility by acknowledging you made a mistake? Or do you undermine your own credibility by acknowledging you made a mistake? Or do
这真的很复杂。一旦一家报纸宣布它将是真实的、中立的、客观的。一旦它宣布它将承担责任，它就会面临一个真正的问题：如果我们搞错了会怎么样？你如何弥补这一点？你会通过承认自己犯了错误来削弱自己的公信力吗？或者你会通过承认自己犯了错误来削弱自己的公信力吗？或者
you undermine your own credibility by ignoring the fact that you made a mistake? So the fall of an authority, I think the sound that the authority makes when he smacks into the forest floor is much louder than the fall of a newspaper that has never been particularly known for accuracy. Your Columbia University's journalism school and your school was called into investigate a prominent story in Rolling Stone magazine. I want you to listen to this clip describing the results of the Columbia University study in Fox News.
你会通过忽视自己犯了错误这一事实来削弱自己的公信力吗？因此，一个权威的倒台，我认为权威砸向森林地面的声音，要比从未以准确闻名的报纸的倒台声音响亮得多。你的哥伦比亚大学新闻学院，你们的学校被召集去调查《滚石》杂志上一篇著名的报道。我希望你听听这段在福克斯新闻上描述哥伦比亚大学研究结果的剪辑。
This is being called a journalistic failure. Columbia University releasing its review of the discredited Rolling Stone article on an alleged gang rape at a University of Virginia fraternity house. So in some ways Andy, this feels like an echo of the 19th century where different publications were trading charges of fake news. Fox News is often accused of peddling fake news by the rest of the mainstream media and here you have Fox News voicing outrage about fake news in another outlet, you know, history repeating itself, right?
这被称为新闻业的失败。哥伦比亚大学发布了其对《滚石》杂志中那篇名誉扫地的文章的审查，该文章涉及弗吉尼亚大学兄弟会宿舍发生的一起所谓的轮奸案。所以在某些方面，安迪，这感觉像是19世纪的回声，当时不同的出版物互相交换假新闻的指控。福克斯新闻经常被其他主流媒体指责兜售假新闻，在这里，你却听到福克斯新闻对另一家媒体的假新闻表示愤怒，你知道的，历史在重演，对吧？
Fake news can be used as an accusation. The term fake news has become almost meaningless because it can be flung in all sorts of contexts like this one, like a very contentious and controversial news organization claiming that another news organization is fake. Fake news can mean anything you want it to mean. It can mean news that is honestly mistaken. It can mean news that is something I don't agree with. It can mean news that says something rude about somebody I support.
假新闻可以被用作一种指控。假新闻这个词几乎失去了意义，因为它可以在各种各样的语境中被抛出，就像这个例子一样，一个极具争议和争议性的新闻机构声称另一个新闻机构是假的。假新闻可以指你想让它指的任何东西。它可以指诚实犯错的新闻。它可以指我不赞同的新闻。它可以指对某个我支持的人说了粗鲁话的新闻。
Using fake news in any kind of debate has become almost ridiculous because it's talking past each other. But it seems to be an inevitable part of any kind of disagreement, of any kind of complaint about the press today. When we come back, we'll take a closer look at the surprising idealism
在任何类型的辩论中使用假新闻已经变得几乎荒谬，因为这是在鸡同鸭讲。但这似乎是任何类型的分歧、对当今媒体的任何类型的抱怨中不可避免的一部分。当我们回来时，我们将仔细看看令人惊讶的理想主义
that often leads to fake news. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. I'm talking this episode with Andy Tucker, who studies history and journalism at Columbia University. One of the fascinating ideas in your work, Andy, is that journalists have resorted to fake news because they think it serves audiences and the public good. So if you needed to cover a devastating tornado in the 19th century, but the telegraph lines were down, and the details of what happened were scarce, your choices were to either say nothing about the disaster or to try and imagine what happened? Yes, there was a real debate about the term faking in the 1880s and 1890s, but it was a debate in which many people argued, many journalists argued,
它往往会导致假新闻。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我在本期节目中与在哥伦比亚大学研究历史和新闻学的安迪·塔克进行了交谈。安迪，你作品中一个迷人的观点是，记者们之所以诉诸假新闻，是因为他们认为这服务于受众和公众利益。所以，如果你需要在19世纪报道一场毁灭性的龙卷风，但电报线断了，发生了什么的细节也很稀少，你的选择要么是对这场灾难闭口不谈，要么就是试图想象发生了什么？是的，在1880年代和1890年代，关于“伪造”这个词确实存在一场辩论，但这是一场许多人争辩、许多记者争辩的辩论，
faking is a good thing. By faking at that time, they didn't mean nefarious manipulation. They meant embellishment, adding some details, filling in gaps that they hadn't been able to see at the time, making an interview-e sound a little more articulate. It wasn't wholesale manipulation, but they argued that people would like that better because it gave them truth that was closer to what they expected, that it gave them stuff that wasn't boring, that nobody wanted a newspaper said one handbook for journalists, nobody wants a newspaper to be a mathematical treatise. You don't want to be crazily accurate. So in the beginning, this term fake news or faking of news was seen as something that journalists
伪造是一件好事。当时的伪造并不是指邪恶的操纵。他们指的是润色、添加一些细节、填补他们当时无法看到的空白、使受访者的声音听起来更清晰一些。这不是大规模的操纵，但他们认为人们会更喜欢这样，因为它给他们提供了更接近他们期望的真相，它给他们提供了不枯燥的东西，没有任何人希望一份报纸，一本新闻手册这样说，没有人希望一份报纸成为一本数学论文。你不需要疯狂地准确。所以一开始，假新闻或伪造新闻这个词被视为记者
could do to make their readers happier. In other words, if the mere recitation of the facts doesn't do justice to the truth, the honest journalist actually goes beyond the facts to try and represent the truth. Yes, yes, you can do a higher truth that way. And that's a term that we hear a lot, you know, somehow getting at a higher truth by glossing over in convenient details. But this was a genuine movement in the early years of the professionalization of the press. There were professional journals in which this argument was made. Do it for your readers, they'll be happier. It's a little self-serving because it also meant that a journalist who was
可以做的事情，以使他们的读者更快乐。换句话说，如果仅仅背诵事实不能公正地对待真相，诚实的记者实际上会超越事实，试图呈现真相。是的，是的，你可以通过这种方式实现更高的真理。这是一个我们经常听到的词，你知道的，通过掩饰不便的细节不知何故达到更高的真理。但这确实是新闻业专业化初期的一场真正的运动。有专业期刊提出了这个论据。为了你的读者这样做，他们会更高兴。这有点自私，因为这也意味着一个有点懒惰的记者
being a little lazy could get away with it. a journalist who wanted to pretend he was a novelist could get away with it. But in general, yes, there was a real sense that it was a good thing to do. And it wasn't just about what the public needs, as you point out, it's also about what the public wants. I'm thinking about the advice that William Hill's gave to newspaper correspondents in 1887. He's basically saying, one reason we should lie to our audiences is because our audiences want us to lie to them. Yeah, it makes them feel better. He had an example of if you're telling the story of a professor who is fascinated into eloping with a young student.
可以蒙混过关。一个想假装自己是小说家的记者可以蒙混过关。但总的来说，是的，人们有一种真正的感觉，这是一件好事。正如你所指出的那样，这不仅关乎公众的需求，还关乎公众的欲望。我想到了威廉·希尔斯在1887年给新闻通讯员的建议。他基本上是说，我们应该对受众撒谎的一个原因是因为我们的受众希望我们对他们撒谎。是的，这让他们感觉更好。他有一个例子，如果你讲一个教授迷恋并与一个年轻学生私奔的故事。
It doesn't hurt anybody, said Hills, to say that the young student was an enchanting 16-year-old brunette instead of the washed out 23-year-old blonde she truly was. It would make people happy. It didn't hurt anybody. They would read your story and they would, the subtext there, of course, be they would buy your newspaper. To be clear, in most newsrooms today, behavior like this will get a journalist fired. This sort of fabrication didn't just happen in newspapers, and he has found that over and over, new technologies opened up new avenues for faking. The irony is, people always have faith that each new technology will make it harder to
希尔斯说，说这个年轻学生是一个迷人的16岁黑发女郎，而不是她真正的那个洗尽铅华的23岁金发女郎，这不会伤害任何人。这会让人们高兴。它不会伤害任何人。他们会读你的故事，他们会，这里的潜台词当然是，他们会买你的报纸。需要明确的是，在当今的大多数新闻编辑室里，这种行为会直接让记者被解雇。这种捏造并不仅限于报纸，安迪发现，新技术不断地为造假开辟了新的途径。讽刺的是，人们总是坚信每一项新技术都会让
manipulate the truth. Early photography was seen when it first was announced in 1839, people like Edgar Allan Poe are talking about how real it is and how you could finally see more real than any kind of art. And within decades, you had someone like William Mumbler who was taking what he called spirit photographs. He would take a portrait of a person and go off and do things in the dark room and bring it back and hovering over the shoulder of
操纵真相变得更加困难。早期摄影在1839年刚宣布时被视为真实的东西，像埃德加·爱伦·坡这样的人在谈论它是多么真实，以及你如何最终看到比任何艺术都更真实的东西。但在几十年内，你就会遇到像威廉·芒布勒这样的人，他拍摄了他所谓的“精神摄影”。他会给一个人拍肖像，然后去暗室里做一些事情，然后拿回来，在照片中那个人的肩膀上方盘旋着的是
the person in the photograph would be the indistinct outline of someone he said was a spirit of a lost loved one. I don't know how he said but my camera can just, you my camera can pick up these spirits, these ghosts, and they show up in the picture. And people loved that. People, this was the year of the Civil War. People were desperate to be in contact with people they had lost. They believed it because the technology seemed so new and magical that they believed it could do anything.
他所说的一个失去的挚爱的灵魂模糊轮廓。我不知道他是怎么说的，但我的相机可以，你知道我的相机可以捕捉到这些灵魂，这些鬼魂，它们会出现在照片中。人们很喜欢这样。人们，这是内战的那一年。人们迫切地想要与他们失去联系的人取得联系。他们相信这一点，因为这项技术看起来如此新颖和神奇，以至于他们相信它能做任何事情。
And now, with the rise of technologies like social media, you know, we were told that, you know, with Twitter and Facebook, you would have 10 million fact checkers, and so we're going to get a more accurate version of reality, but we also now have 10 million publishers putting out their own facts and theories all the time. The Internet is really challenging
现在，随着社交媒体等技术的发展，你知道，有人告诉我们，你知道的，有了推特和脸书，你就会有1000万个事实核查员，因此我们将获得更准确的现实版本，但我们现在也有1000万个出版商一直在发布他们自己的事实和理论。互联网真的具有挑战性
because it's so hard to know the difference. You go on one page and yes, it is a page where of a serious news organization that has fact checkers and has editors and has codes of ethics. And then you go to another page and it looks physically very similar, but it's got completely different approach to news and it can be very hard for a casual browser to understand the difference. They seem to be similar, but the content can end up being radically different.
因为很难知道区别。你进入一个页面，是的，这是一个有事实核查员、有编辑、有道德准则的严肃新闻机构的页面。然后你进入另一个页面，它在外观上非常相似，但它对新闻采取了完全不同的方法，对于随意的浏览者来说，要理解其中的区别可能非常困难。它们看起来可能很相似，但内容最终可能会截然不同。
So the history is very good at telling us that the things we think of as dramatic and new might only be iterations of what's happened in the past, but are you really saying there's no difference between our current moment and earlier ones? I mean, specifically looking at the Trump administration and its relationship with the truth, its constant war with the press. Are you really saying this is only just more of the same? No, I think there are consequential differences in what's going on now in the Trump administration.
所以历史非常擅长告诉我们，我们认为戏剧性和崭新的东西可能只是过去发生的事情的迭代，但你真的是在说我们当前的时刻和早期时刻之间没有任何区别吗？我的意思是，具体着眼于特朗普政府及其与真相的关系、它与媒体的持续战争？你真的在说这只是更多的同类事件吗？不，我认为特朗普政府现在正在发生的事情有实质性的不同。
Some very important and nerve-wracking differences. I don't know of another time in which an administration so uniformly and vigorously and constantly works to undermine and diminish journalism as having any relationship with the truth. It is not even an argument about facts so much as an argument about you cannot trust those guys, they're deceitful, they're dishonest, it's a very emotional argument. And I think to have no place that's to stand, it leaves truth telling no place to stand and i find that really dangerous to uh to the idea of a democracy and when you think about that uh that danger uh is there a way for ordinary citizens to think their way through this i mean if you are an average person in the country and you constantly hear claims of fake news being hurled from every direction and every other direction. It's just easy to throw up your hands and say, why should I trust anything?
一些非常重要且让人神经紧张的不同。我不知道还有什么时候，一个行政当局如此统一、有力且不断地致力于破坏和贬低新闻业与真相有任何关系。这甚至不是关于事实的争论，而更多的是关于你不能信任那些家伙，他们是虚伪的、不诚实的，这是一个非常情绪化的争论。我认为，如果没有一个可以立足的地方，这让说真话的人无处立足，我发现这对民主理念来说真的很危险；当你想到那种危险时，普通公民有什么方法可以思考通过这一点吗？我的意思是，如果你是这个国家的普通人，你不断听到来自各个方向和各个其他方向的关于假新闻的指控。人们很容易一摊手说，我为什么要相信任何事情？
That's a danger. A danger that worries me and many other journalists very, very much. There are many scholars and many journalists who are desperately trying to figure out ways to address the failing trust in news, the rush of fake news. It's really difficult. There are people who say that training and media literacy will help. There are people who say that news organizations need to be more transparent.
这是一个危险。一个让我和许多其他记者非常非常担心的危险。有许多学者和许多记者正在拼命寻找方法来解决对新闻业日益丧失的信任以及假新闻的泛滥。这真的很难。有些人说，培训媒体素养会有所帮助。有些人说，新闻机构需要更加透明。
In Europe, there are various governmental or quasi-governmental efforts to various governmental or quasi-governmental efforts to regulate what's available, what's possible. Malaysia has passed a law criminalizing fake news. Italy, you can report it to the police. These are all efforts and I think we need to keep making efforts, but I'm not sure what will help other than the public, the citizenry, maintaining its vigilance and refusing to throw up its hands and give up and insisting on reading with courage, with skepticism, with an open mind and engaging in open debate. Speaking of government regulation, I want to end by going back to one of the earliest cases of fake news in American history. You describe a case from 1690 and you say that the story
在欧州，有各种政府或准政府努力来监管什么可用，什么可行。马来西亚通过了一项将假新闻定为刑事犯罪的法律。在意大利，你可以向警方举报。这些都是努力，我认为我们需要继续努力，但除了公众、公民保持警惕、拒绝一摊手放弃并坚持以勇气、怀疑精神、开放的心态进行阅读并参与公开辩论之外，我不确定还有什么会有所帮助。说到政府监管，我想以回到美国历史上最早的假新闻案例之一来结束。你描述了1690年的一个案例，你说这个故事
led to an extraordinary 14 year period when American newspapers published absolutely no fake news. What happened? In 1690, the very first newspaper published in North America public occurrences. He came to Boston, Benjamin Harris, he was from London, and he set himself up as just a guy named Ben who was going to publish a newspaper to tell the truth. And he had a list at the top of what he was going to do. I'm going to tell the truth if I find that people are not telling the truth. I will expose them. I will give people the information they need.
导致了一个非同寻常的14年时期，当时美国报纸绝对没有发表任何假新闻。发生了什么？在1690年，北美出版的第一份报纸《公众纪事》。他来到波士顿，本杰明·哈里斯，他来自伦敦，他把自己设定为一个名叫本的普通人，他要出版一份报纸来讲述真相。他在顶部列出了他要做的事情清单。如果我发现人们没有说实话，我会说实话。我会揭露他们。我会给人们他们需要的信息。
I will use only the best sources. So it sounded very modern. He then published a piece that claimed that the king of France, Louis the 14th, was sleeping with his daughter in law, which could have been a mistake, but I think it was fake news in a very modern sense intended to undermine the king because of the religious tensions at the time. The king was a fervent Catholic, Paris was not, Paris was a Protestant. I think he published that news, knowing it was not true,
我只会使用最好的消息来源。所以这听起来很现代。然后他发表了一篇文章，声称法国国王路易十四与他的儿媳妇睡觉，这可能是一个错误，但我认为这是现代意义上的假新闻，旨在因为当时宗教紧张局势而破坏国王。国王是狂热的天主教徒，巴黎不是，巴黎是新教徒。我认为他发表这条新闻时就知道这不是真的，
because the king didn't have a daughter-in-law, and did it in order to undermine the king. He was shut down immediately, because this was seen as something impossible for an ordinary person to do, to be so critical, saying whatever he wanted. And then for the next 14 years, there was no fake news published in America, because for
因为国王没有儿媳妇，这样做是为了破坏国王的信誉。他立即被关闭，因为这被认为是一个普通人不可能做到的事情，如此具有批判性，想说什么就说什么。然后在接下来的14年里，美国没有发表任何假新闻，因为在
the next 14 years, there were no newspapers published in America. Andy Tucker is a professor at Columbia University. She's the author of Froth and Scum, and a forthcoming book on fake news. Its working title is Misinformed. Andy, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much. This week's show was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and other Thiband LeMoodie.
接下来的14年里，美国没有出版任何报纸。安迪·塔克是哥伦比亚大学的教授。她是《浮沫与渣滓》的作者，也是一本即将出版的关于假新闻的书的作者。它的暂定名是《被误导》。安迪，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙阿、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和其他蒂班·勒穆迪。
Our unsung hero this week is Jerry Holmes. Jerry is the deputy managing editor of NPR News. In an era where the demands and pressures of journalism can feel really intense, Jerry's the type of editor you want to have by your side. He's always calm, he's always thoughtful, and he manages the many tensions of a modern newsroom with a skilled hand. Thank you, Jerry. You make our journalism better. You can find more hidden brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like the show, please let others know and leave us a review on iTunes. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR.
我们本周的无名英雄是杰里·霍姆斯。杰里是NPR新闻的副执行主编。在新闻业的要求和压力感觉非常激烈的时代，杰里正是你希望身边的编辑类型。他总是很平静，他总是很周到，并且以娴熟的手法处理现代新闻编辑室的种种紧张关系。谢谢你，杰里。你让我们的新闻业变得更好。你可以在脸书和推特上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》。如果你喜欢这个节目，请让其他人知道并在iTunes上给我们留下评论。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您还没有为本集发表评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。